he is getting set to be in the final
four taking on the kansas jayhawks
coming up this weekend
and he is the two-time big east player
of the year and a national champion back
in 2018 on villanova he is on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line right now
colin gillespie here on the program how
are you sir
i'm good how are you guys i'm good i
don't know if you heard uh prior if
you're on hold hearing that but you
broke my heart are you aware of that
colin you wear that twice you've done
that i did hear you i apologize okay now
do you really mean that or are you just
drinking in my tears colin you strike me
as a very uh uh competitive individual
you can be honest nah
i i do apologize but i had to be done
i understand
uh i i completely understand how does
this run
now remind you of the successful run you
had a a couple years ago is there
anything that that is somewhat similar
that you feel right now colin um
a little bit i guess i think there's two
very very different teams uh every year
is different so
um
i think it's a little different but
obviously being in san antonio having to
play michigan again was definitely
similar
um but yeah i think the years are
different the teams are different so
it's more different than similar
okay and so um being in san antonio and
beating michigan is is what you said is
similar so i actually
once we have turned the page from me
telling you that you broke my heart i
asked you a question that strolled me
right back into that situation is that
what you're telling me colin
oh my gosh it's just i keep taking uh
blocking fouls here this is uh
unfortunate um okay so then um let's
talk about um your coach and your
relationship with him when did you first
meet jay wright colin when did that
first happen for you
i met him when i was a senior in high
school uh he had come to
a couple of our uh of my high school
games to recruit and uh that's when i
met him and then i came to school to
visit and i saw him again so when did he
did did
is it true let's put it this way then is
it true you did not have any d1 offers
going into your senior year of high
school is that a true fact
uh yeah i was uh
my junior summer so going into my senior
year
uh i picked up two very late in the
summer
during aau to maine and albany and that
was the only two that i had so wayne
into my career so when jay wright
strolls in um he he must have had your
attention i would imagine
yeah they did obviously i'm a local kid
from northeast philadelphia so
um
obviously when villanova came calling i
noticed right away and um i went and
visited it and
uh the guys were great it was a family
environment so it was something that i
wanted to be a part of who were the guys
who were the guys at the time when you
first started uh when i first got when i
visited it was like josh hart chris
jenkins and
uh daryl reynolds were seniors but then
when i visited i visited and i was uh
with jalen mchale dante eric phil omari
um all those guys
so who do you hear from um when you're
now doing this you know as the leader of
this team a fifth year kid who do you
hear from uh from back in the day when
you look at your phone maybe after a big
win or something like that
all of them
all of them uh
those guys are uh yeah we stay in
contact those guys are like my brothers
and um we stay in contact all the time i
mean i talked to jalen every day
um and then i'm always talking to
mikhail
uh dante and phil is overseas right now
so the time time zones are really off
but uh
hill texas it'll be like three in the
morning and uh so we all stay in contact
how about any of the old school guys
kyle lowry do you hear from him do you
hear any of any some old school wildcats
well yeah kyle's from uh philly so
uh he's around all the time in the
summer and he's always talking to our
guys i think really cool about the the
culture and the program is that
those guys are always back around in the
summer times and uh they're always a
phone call or text away and
they love to be talking with us so but
yeah we thought kyle lowry
[Music]
randy foy is around a lot and
alan ray is always talking to us so some
of those guys and
obviously we have coaches on the staff
who played so
the culture is strong here and guys
always want to come back so then before
we we move on to i guess the here and
now a little bit what makes colin
gillespie here on the rich eisen show
what makes jay wright so good
give me an insight where you as a player
were like okay
this is this is we're in such great
hands you got an example of that that
you can
yeah i mean i think player development
is a reason why i chose villanova they
developed their players really well and
everybody gets better but i think it's
more
non-basketball related just life
the lessons he teach you about life and
becoming a man having to grow up and
you know that when you leave here you're
going to become a man and you're going
to be ready to take on whatever life
throws at you i think that's the
the biggest thing that i've taken away
from being here at villanova
and what's the life lesson can you give
me an example of that
uh i mean one thing that we talk about
every day is attitude and um how you
respond to certain situations whether
you're on the basketball floor or not uh
it could be you're in foul trouble on
the basketball on the court and
kind of just have to say attitude and uh
go make the next play and i think that's
the same thing in life with life
situations uh you might be throwing a
situation at you that you weren't
expecting or
um that you weren't ready for but
uh that's life and you kind of have to
adjust and just move on and do the next
right thing so
i think that's
yeah and i just think in in in terms of
doing the right thing and and and being
there and living in the moment uh colin
i could not help but notice um that once
you know
once the buzzer sounded game over
against houston
first thing you did was go right up to
justin moore at the end of the bench and
sit right down next to him
and um so i i just want to have you walk
me through
you know i know why you did it but i'd
like to hear from you why you did it and
what was going on at the time
colin gillespie um
yeah i mean i knew he was hurt uh but
when he when he went down obviously he's
a huge part of our team
uh both offensive offensively and
defensively but as a leader he's been
so crucial for our young guys and he
stepped into a bigger role this year as
a leader and
for me to just go over there and i've
been in that situation before
last year being injured and
going down late in the season right
before the tournament his
just happened in the elite eight game uh
right before he went to the final four
so
that's a really tough situation to be in
um and i was sad for him i was sad for
our team and
losing a guy like that is it hurts but
uh
our guys are going to play for him
they're going to step up but i just
wanted to go over there and
kind of just try to be there for him i
knew he was upset you could see it on
his face and
after winning the game like that
uh i didn't want to see him upset so i
just wanted to go over there be there
for him and
uh kind of just let him know that uh we
had his back and
he was gonna he was gonna be all right
what was he saying like what was the
conversation if you don't mind me crying
along yeah right there um
i i asked him well i originally i told
him um like we got you like
you're going to be all right like you're
going to bounce back and uh we're going
to get you healthy and we're going to
get this thing done for you and
um
i mean obviously i saw he was upset and
i we started talking about what had
happened because he thought
that he was tripped like he got tripped
by a ref or kicked by the ref and
obviously when you tear your achilles
your first immediate instinct is to look
back
because you you feel like you tripped on
something or somebody hit you but
i originally thought he had just slipped
or rolled his ankle again because
um his ankle has been rolled before so
that was my immediate thought and then
once he told me
that it was numb and he stood up and he
couldn't really put any pressure on it
it was a little bit more serious and
after i had heard that and i could see
he was emotional that i just kind of
wanted to be there for him and
let him know that i had his back and i
was there for him
well you're a good man i saw that and i
thought to myself that is exactly what a
leader does that's what uh you know um a
a sense of brotherhood of man
does and um i saw that and it was also
good to see him part of the the ceremony
you know once once i guess the
the latter came out and and you know
that he was part of it that was pretty
cool too
colin yeah yeah i definitely wanted him
to be a part of that i mean he's a huge
part of our team so
not having him there would have been
right colin gillespie a couple more
minutes left with a two-time big east
player of the year for villanova i mean
you you you're
you get what's going on in the world in
the conversation you know duke unc we're
all making a big deal of it in the media
kansas has just got the most wins in the
history of the ncaa
world um and now you're a man short
second leading scorer and justin moore
do you think you're going to be the
overlooked team going into this
weekend
colin gillespie
uh i mean we don't really look at it we
don't pay attention to it obviously
it definitely hurts not having justin
there just in terms of leadership
uh and his presence on the floor
uh as a scorer and as a guy who guards
the best player
uh every time that we we go out so
it's definitely going to hurt but
our other guys are going to step up and
they're going to be in different roles
caleb daniels came off the bench all
year but he was a starter all last year
so
it's not
not new for him
and then other guys are going to be
playing the bigger roles and
have more time with the ball in their
hands and have to be decision makers and
we'll have a few guys come off the bench
that need to play some more valuable
minutes so i think guys are going to
step up and they're going to be ready
and prepared for
the moment and excited to play how do
you view your role in this moment
yeah
i mean obviously i'll have the ball in
my hands a little bit more with justin
being down but i think for us nothing
changes its next man up mentality they
did it last year when i went down and
i was really proud of those guys and
i think it's the same thing this year
we're gonna have to just step up for him
and
play for him and guys are going to step
up and be in different bigger roles
myself included and
i think we're ready i think we're going
to be prepared we obviously didn't have
him in the middle of the year for a game
which was tough but
it's not a super new situation for us
because we we did miss him in the middle
of the year for a game all right last
couple things for you uh colin um i just
know that my dad he's uh he passed away
a couple years ago but uh the reason why
i bring him up here is that if he was
ever wired up during a performance of
mine
and recorded and shown to a nationally
televised audience i would be nervous
the entire time i just you know so
did you know your dad was wearing a wire
for the broadcast a couple of weeks ago
or last week you were there no i did not
i
found out afterwards and
i went on uh twitter and i everybody was
tweeting about him i was like what like
why are people talking about them
and uh
and then it was in my family group chat
my brother said something about like dad
was the star of the night or something
like that
um
i was laughing obviously yeah i do get
really nervous because he uh
they probably put all the good parts on
there and
uh didn't get him cursing at all which
was probably the best for the best but
uh
yeah i didn't know right away until
after the game and then somebody let him
get on for the elite eight game against
houston and i was like who put this guy
back
this guy up again
who allowed him to be micked up again
for another game
so i don't know if you're uh i was
watching um and um
it was just a bunch of like yeah you
know like way to go or go get it like
just that's that's it and i was just
wondering to ask you like that that's
that's not the way he talks right now
how he normally he was eating that up
for sure
uh making himself look good but yeah
he's a coach at heart so he coached
football in high school so i've seen him
and he coached me in my entire life so
i know what he's really like and
they just made him look good obviously i
think they probably
didn't get all the parts where he may
have uh
felt a certain way so they yeah the
thing thank goodness for editing
equipment is what you're saying colin
gillespie okay seriously all right and
then the last thing too is i i know
we've just met and um
but your coach if you can tell him
something because again we're
we hope to get him on shortly but maybe
i'll just use you as a conduit um
with with the you know whole world um
changing over the last two years in the
sports world um it appears coaches have
stopped wearing suits in the basketball
world and they're just dressing like
they're going to the gym you know what i
mean it's it's it's giving up i'll be
honest um and i'm a suit and tie guy the
one guy who i'm most lamenting no longer
wearing a suit is is your coach who
would dress you know like he's
he's you know a loan officer or you know
like an old school
gangster you know what i mean like and
and so what gives can you ask him
essentially like what gives
where the suits are where is it i think
i think he's comfortable uh
in his uh what he's wearing right now
with a little quarter zip and uh i mean
nobody no no other coaches wear suits
besides uh some guy i don't even know if
the guys in the nba are right now but uh
no ucla his coach does ucla's coach does
and um but no one in the nba does any
more but j i mean
i don't think the big east i think the
big east was they came together as
coaches and
said that they weren't going to wear
them this year
uh so i think they made that decision
but
i don't know i mean i think i think they
look good they got some nice nike uh zip
ups over there and uh they're probably
comfortable can probably move a little
bit more freely on the sideline
i just don't know i just i just like the
way he dressed and i i i'm
very well dressed don't you think i mean
there's uh i don't know his message i
think might come through better even if
it's
he's dressed he cleans up nicely oh
pinstripe he always wore the pinstripes
he did but all right just tell him for
me you know uh
i miss it i know that's weird but just
do that hello colin good luck man uh
again um you know i appreciate the time
and the ability for me to tell you that
uh you ripped my heart out twice but
that's okay
um as you said it had to be done for you
and good luck against kansas and beyond
i look forward to watching you play i
really enjoy watching him
thank you i appreciate it you bet that's
colin gillespie right here on the rich
eisen show
getting ready to take on kansas i knew
his dad wasn't talking like that
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here